Roman Mars. Ben, Brock Johnson. So you were a father of twins. I am a father of twins. I would like to introduce you to one of my twins. This is my son who got the name I always wanted. Brock Johnson. Hello, Roman Mawes.
罗曼·马尔斯。本、布洛克·约翰逊。所以你是个双胞胎父亲。我是个双胞胎父亲。我想向你介绍我的一个双胞胎。这是我的儿子，他拥有我一直想要的名字。布洛克·约翰逊。你好，罗曼·莫斯。
Oh, you're fired. This kid's coming for you. He'll have my resignation on his desk on Monday morning. for sure. That's right. Brock is doing what a lot of eight-year-olds do these days. He is designing a very ridiculous tree house that I do not have the ability or the resources to construct. He is riding his bike as fast as possible. And he is starting to play, just starting to play video games, which offer him this whole universe of different worlds to inhabit. He likes smashing things just as much as the next eight-year-old or 45-year-old in my case.
哦，你被解雇了。这小子要来取代你了。周一早上他绝对会把我的辞职信放在办公桌上。没错。布洛克现在在做很多八岁小孩都会做的事。他在设计一个非常荒谬的树屋，而我既没有能力也没有资源去建造它。他正以最快的速度骑着自行车。而且他开始玩电子游戏，刚开始玩，游戏为他提供了一个充满不同世界的广阔宇宙供他居住。他喜欢砸东西，就像我身边的任何八岁或四十五岁的人一样。
But, you know, when I asked him about what he really loves about playing video games, he's not just about smashing things. He's about game environments. I play a lot of the tundra biome and sometimes the forest biome. Forest biome? Yeah. What do you like about the forest in video games? You can really transform the forest into a nice home.
但是，你知道的，当我问他最喜欢玩电子游戏什么地方时，他不仅仅喜欢砸东西。他喜欢游戏里的环境。我经常玩苔原生物群系，有时也玩森林生物群系。森林生物群系？对。你喜欢电子游戏里的森林什么？你真的可以把森林变成一个温馨的家。
And there's really cool bushes. Sometimes I really like the bushes. I can always be like, hmm, is there something tangled up at this bush? And it's really fun to imagine what could happen. And sometimes it does happen. You know, I've never heard an eight-year-old use the word biome so much. Like, he's just really, like, insorseled by the outside world inside of his, you know, indoor kids game. I know. He really is. And the first time he said it, it was sort of a record scratch for me. But I can see why. You know, the games that you and I played when we were growing up, right, they're really simplistic in the way that they depict or capture natural environments. But games now are getting really good at rendering things like bushes that might have something tangled up in them and trees. It is way more realistic and immersive than it used to be.
里面还有非常酷的灌木丛。有时我真的很喜欢这些灌木丛。我总是会想，嗯，这个灌木丛里是不是缠着什么东西？想象一下可能会发生什么真的很有趣。有时它确实会发生。你知道的，我从来没听过一个八岁小孩这么频繁地使用“生物群系”这个词。就好像他真的被他那室内儿童游戏里的外部世界深深迷住了。我知道。他确实如此。他第一次说这个词的时候，对我来说就像是唱片跳针了一样。但我能理解为什么。你知道的，你和我小时候玩的游戏，它们在描绘或捕捉自然环境的方式上真的很简单。但现在的游戏在渲染像可能缠着东西的灌木丛和树木这样的事物时变得非常出色。它比以前逼真得多，也更有沉浸感。
And that's what we're going to talk about today. This is Hidden Levels, how the world of video games is changing the world beyond video games. Endless threads, senior producer Dean Russell takes it from here. Cassie Ann was raised to be what you might call outdoorsy. A wild child of the mid-aughts, dirt under fingernails, grass on the knees. Cassie was a rain or shine kid. I was outside all of the time, at least when I could be, because we do have very harsh winters here sometimes. Though that never stopped me.
而这正是我们今天要谈论的内容。这里是“隐藏关卡”，探讨电子游戏世界如何改变电子游戏之外的世界。无限连线，高级制作人迪恩·拉塞尔从这里开始。卡西·安从小就被培养成那种你可能会说是热爱户外的人。那是2000年代中期的一个野孩子，指甲缝里有泥土，膝盖上有青草。卡西是个无论风雨无阻的孩子。我总是待在户外，至少在我能做到的时候，因为我们这里有时会有非常严酷的冬天。尽管这从未阻止过我。
Sometimes I would just go out in the snow and be completely soaked. Cassie and their family lived in rural Vermont, a beautiful spot east of Lake Champlain in a valley of pine and birch and oak and maple. Some of Cassie's favorite things. Giant trees. Big into trees. Nature was everything. A place they could explore. It was a place to hang with friends, a place to build forts and fairy villages, a place to be.
有时我只是走到雪地里，浑身湿透。卡西和他们的家人住在佛蒙特州的乡村，那是尚普兰湖东岸一个美丽的地方，位于松树、桦树、橡树和枫树的山谷中。卡西最喜欢的一些东西。巨树。非常喜欢树。大自然就是一切。一个他们可以探索的地方。这是一个和朋友闲逛的地方，一个建造堡垒和仙女村的地方，一个存在的地方。
In those early years of life, nature felt limitless. It felt good. Until one day, it didn't. I was like 10 or 12, like somewhere in that early second decade. And I was out playing with my friends. I had a lot of friends who had like farms growing up and we loved to play in the hay bales. On that day, when Cassie tired themselves out and came inside, they noticed something.
在生命的早期阶段，大自然感觉是无限的。感觉很好。直到有一天，不再如此了。我当时大概10岁或12岁，大约在那个生命第二个十年的早期。我和朋友们在外面玩。我有很多小时候有农场的朋友，我们喜欢在干草堆里玩。那天，当卡西玩累了走进屋里时，他们注意到了一些东西。
Cassie's skin was red, puffy, itchy. Honestly, it was a little scary. I never had that reaction before, and I don't know where it came from. And so, like, their mom was, like, giving me Benadryl and, you know, the creams and stuff like that. But it was so bad I had to go home in the middle of the sleepover. And I was like, I was just so embarrassed. This reaction was new. It felt invasive and confusing.
卡西的皮肤又红、又肿、又痒。说实话，这有点吓人。我以前从未有过这种反应，而且我不知道它是从哪里来的。所以，就像，我妈妈给我吃苯海拉明，你知道的，还有乳霜之类的东西。但情况太严重了，我不得不在睡衣派对中途回家。我当时觉得，我真是太尴尬了。这种反应是全新的。它让人感到具有侵入性且令人困惑。
It went away, but they didn't know what it was. On another day, Cassie went to the beach. Suddenly, they felt awful, feverish even. These episodes became more frequent. Pretty soon, rashes and fevers developed. It felt like almost every time they went outside. They saw doctors who couldn't give a clear singular diagnosis. What they did come to know is that they are allergic to hay,
它消失了，但他们不知道那是什么。又有一天，卡西去了海滩。突然间，他们感觉糟透了，甚至开始发烧。这些发作变得更加频繁。很快，皮疹和发烧就出现了。感觉几乎每次他们出门都会这样。他们看过的医生无法给出明确单一的诊断。他们后来了解到的是，他们对干草过敏，
allergic to grass, immunocompromised, extremely sensitive to the heat of the sun, or as some put it, allergic to the sun. It was like their body had decided enough with the outdoors. I mean, I just kind of became a little bit of a shut-in, I guess, which is sort of expected. I just kind of retreated into my room. Very much so. And, you know, I'd have the window open if I could,
对草过敏，免疫力低下，对太阳的热量极其敏感，或者正如某些人所说，对太阳过敏。这就像他们的身体已经决定受够了户外。我的意思是，我猜我最后变得有点像个闭门不出的人了，这其实也算意料之中。我差不多就是退缩到了自己的房间里。确实如此。而且，你知道的，如果可以的话我会把窗户打开，
but I definitely stopped spending time outside. Doctors didn't know what caused Cassie's body to turn on them, or if they'd ever get better. They still don't know. What is clear is that Cassie, someone who loved the outdoors, who thrived with their hands in the dirt, had to become a lot more indoorsy.
但我确实停止了在户外逗留。医生们不知道是什么导致卡西的身体开始排斥他们，也不知道他们是否会好转。他们现在仍然不知道。显而易见的是，卡西这个热爱户外、双手沾满泥土就能生机勃勃的人，不得不变得更加宅在家中。
But they couldn't give up. They had to find another way to get it. And for a kid in the 2000s, there was one obvious place to turn. What's your favorite game? Oh, Minecraft. Sorry. I'm really excited there. Cassie freaking loves Minecraft.
但他们不能放弃。他们必须找到另一种途径来获得它。对于2000年代的一个孩子来说，有一个显而易见的地方可以转向。你最喜欢的游戏是什么？哦，我的世界。抱歉。我在这里真的很兴奋。卡西超级喜欢《我的世界》。
Minecraft is, by the numbers, the most popular video game in the world. Over 350 million copies have been sold. since it launched in 2009. The spinoff Jack Black movie, which you probably heard of, grossed nearly a billion dollars this year. Anything you can dream about here, you can make zero limits. You know what I'm talking about. The game is a Lego-like world of 16 pixel by 16 pixel by 16 pixel blocks.
从数据上看，《我的世界》是世界上最受欢迎的电子游戏。自2009年推出以来，已售出超过3.5亿份。你可能听说过的衍生杰克·布莱克电影，今年的票房接近十亿美元。在这里你能梦想到的任何东西，你都可以创造，零限制。你知道我在说什么。这款游戏是一个由16像素乘16像素乘16像素的方块组成的乐高般的世界。
The trees are blocks, the animals, the rocks, all blocks. Minecraft has no points, no prescribed goal, really. You mine with pickaxes and punch trees for lumber. Yeah, punch trees. Then you can build or not. One of the things Cassie enjoyed most in the game was walking, walking around in the game and exploring, because Minecraft is a virtually endless world of forests,
树木是方块，动物、岩石，全部都是方块。没有积分，没有规定的目标，真的。《我的世界》里，你用镐挖矿，用拳头砍树来获取木材。没错，用拳头砍树。然后你可以选择建造，或者不建造。卡西在游戏中最大的乐趣之一就是在游戏中四处走动、闲逛和探索，因为《我的世界》是一个几乎无限的森林世界，
farmlands, deserts, oceans, caves, you name it. It became Cassie's point. portal to the outdoors. I started playing it, like, pretty much every day. I had my little server with my friends, and whenever my friends would kind of burn out from it and play something else, I would just go in my single player world and build. It kind of never mattered to me that, like, the Minecraft environments were, like, 16 by 16 pixels or whatever, because in my head, I was, like, I was so familiar with that feeling of, like,
农田、沙漠、海洋、洞穴，应有尽有。它成为了卡西通往户外的门户。我开始玩它，几乎每天都玩。我和朋友们有我的小服务器，每当我的朋友们玩腻了去玩别的游戏时，我就会独自进入我的单人世界去建造。对我来说，这似乎从来不重要，比如《我的世界》的环境是16乘16像素还是别的什么，因为在我的脑海里，我当时觉得，我对那种走过树林、置身户外的感觉太熟悉了，以至于它直接转化成了我在游戏中的体验。这是《我的世界》生成的地形。这是一个专门用于饲养牲畜的监视仓。对，你还有一个蝴蝶园……这里有一些蝌蚪。你能看到它们。哦，你知道我们在水下。
walking through the woods and being outside, that it kind of just translated into my experiences in game. This is like Minecraft-generated terrain. This is a monitor barn that's specifically for livestock. Yeah, and you got like a butterfly garden and... There's some tadpoles in here. You can see them. Oh, you know we're underwater.
卡西现在22岁了，他们以“Snifferish”这个《我的世界》ID而更为人知。Snifferish是一个《我的世界》网红。他们在互联网上很有名。在TikTok、Twitch和YouTube之间，他们拥有大约300万粉丝。人们观看长达数小时的视频，看Snifferish建造一些最精致的风景。在我最初的视频中，那是一个农场视频，我建造了一个火塘。每个人都问什么是火塘？我说……其中一些建筑需要几个月的时间才能完成。我建造了这个非常经典的白色农舍，然后这是一个监视仓，这是一个专门用于牲畜的谷仓。Snifferish甚至被《我的世界》的制作方委托设计微型世界。
Cassie is now 22, and they are better known by their Minecraft handle Snifferish. Snifferish is a Minecraft influencer. They are internet famous. Between TikTok, Twitch, and YouTube, they have some 3 million followers. People who watch hours-long videos of Snifferish building some of the most elaborate landscapes. When in my first videos, it was like a farm video, and I built a fire pond. And everyone was like, what is a fire pond? And I was like, some of these builds will take months to make. I built this very classic white farmhouse, and then this is a monitor barn, which is a barn that's specifically for livestock. Snifferish has even been commissioned by the makers of Minecraft to design mini-worlds.
哦，天哪。现在我们在背景中有了巨大的山脉。这一切都是因为Snifferish，也就是卡西，对游戏的虚拟自然有着独特的理解，这种自然对于卡西和许多其他人来说，感觉相当真实。我确信电子游戏让人对大自然产生兴趣，因为他们看到了从未体验过的自然，这让他们几乎想去亲身体验一下。然后反过来，你知道的，有些人本来就对大自然感兴趣，因此才会因为这个而开始玩电子游戏。
Oh, my gosh. Now we've got giant mountains in the background. All because Snifferish, Cassie, has a unique understanding of the game's virtual nature, a nature that, for Cassie and many others, feels quite real. I know for a fact that video games make people interested in nature because they're seeing nature that they've never experienced before and it's making them almost want to go experience it. And then in turn, you know, you have people who are already interested in nature and therefore get into video games because of that.
电子游戏可以说是大自然的对立面，高度构建的世界，合成的、无机的。如果你是在游戏伴随下长大的，你可能还记得大人们叫你关掉游戏机，去户外呼吸一下新鲜空气。不过如今，“呼吸新鲜空气”已经不再是必须去户外才能做的事情了。随着游戏业发展成为一个2000亿美元的产业，屏幕与泥土之间的界限已经变得模糊。新技术和各种游戏方式正在让游戏玩家们，
Video games are arguably the antithesis. of nature, highly constructed worlds, synthetic, inorganic. If you grew up gaming, you may recall grown-ups telling you to shut down the console, go outside and touch some grass. These days, though, touching grass isn't something you have to do outside. As gaming has grown into a $200 billion industry, the boundary between screen and soil has muddied. New technologies and types of play are getting gamers,
越来越接近真实自然的体验。然而，在一个奇怪的反馈循环中，那些旨在模拟自然的相同技术和游戏方式现在正以可能超越我们所有人的方式改变着真实的世界。自游戏历史开始以来，虚拟自然扮演了许多角色，服务于许多目的，并以许多方式被呈现。
ever closer to the experience of real nature. And yet, in a kind of weird feedback loop, those same technologies and types of play meant to simulate nature are now changing the real thing in ways that could outlast us all. Since the start of gaming history, virtual nature has played many roles, served many purposes, and been represented in many ways.
《太空大战》，一款1962年在圆形屏幕计算机上的游戏，可能是第一个带有“所谓”自然、太空的游戏，也就是黑色背景上的白点。随着游戏的发展，虚拟自然也在演变。与该行业的惯例一样，它通常是朝着更高的逼真度和更高的准确度推进的。阿琳达·张是加州大学圣巴巴拉分校的教授，也是一名游戏玩家。阿琳达研究电子游戏生态学，并为此写了一本书。为什么一个学者要在游戏中研究生态学？对许多人来说，那是他们日常的剂量，无论如何，那是他们每周接触自然环境的剂量，
Space War, a 1962 game on a circular screen computer, was maybe the first with quote-unquote nature, space, aka white dots on a black backdrop. When games advanced, virtual nature also evolved. As always with the industry, it's usually a push toward more verisimilitude and toward more accuracy. Alenda Chang is a professor at UC Santa Barbara, and a gamer. Alenda studies video game ecology, wrote a book on it. Why would an academic study ecology in games? For a lot of people, that is their daily dosage or whatever, their weekly dosage of encounter with the natural environment.
对吧，或者至少是自然环境的表征。是的，我这周没有去徒步旅行，但我去过海拉鲁的山脉，所以，你知道的，就是这样。哦，太棒了。海拉鲁王国，塞尔达，她懂的。《塞尔达传说》是任天堂的长青系列，拥有几十款游戏，实际上是自然在游戏历史中如何演变的一个好例子。任天堂以及《塞尔达传说》系列本身，总是在游戏中自然表征的前沿。你可以把电子游戏大自然的演变思考为三个大时代，三个伟大的塞尔达时代。让我们从第一时代开始。
right, or at least the representation of a natural environment. Yeah, I haven't been hiking this week, but I have been to the mountains of Hyrule, so, you know, there's that. Oh, excellent. Hyrule Kingdom, Zelda, she gets it. The Legend of Zelda, Nintendo's long-running franchise with dozens of games, is actually a good example of how nature has evolved throughout gaming history. There is something about Nintendo and also the Zelda franchise itself that has always been at the forefront of natural representation in games. You can think of video game nature's evolution in three big eras, three big Zelda's. Let's start with Era 1.
第一部塞尔达游戏于1986年问世。它是二维的，八位的。你扮演林克，一个尖耳朵的战士，在海拉鲁的魔法世界里，从一个没有裤子、邪恶的野猪怪物手中拯救塞尔达公主。林克是一个扁平的像素化人物，在湖泊和洞穴的扁平、像素化近似物上移动。你看到最新的任天堂新闻通讯了吗？哇，画面真不错。我很想上手玩那个游戏。从角色本身到一切都占据着一个非常离散的正方形或长方形。
The first Zelda game comes out in 1986. It's two-dimensional, eight-bit. You play as Link, a pointy-eared warrior. saving Princess Zelda from a panceless evil hog monster in the magical world of Hyrule. Link is a flat, pixelated figure moving over flat, pixelated approximations of lakes and caves. Did you see the latest Nintendo newsletter? Whoa, nice graphics. I'd like to get my hands on that game. Everything down to the character itself occupies a very discreet square or rectangle.
你知道的，所以如果是森林，所有的树木都是一样的，它们以网格状复制，对吧，或者是石头之类的东西。所以你会有一种感觉，就像这一切都是非常精心放置的，并且在风景的意义上具有风景画的特点。正如大多数游戏一样，大自然只不过是背景，是一个布景。所以，来到第二时代。快进十年，来到游戏的3D时期，当时包括塞尔达在内的游戏开始将自然置于其玩法的核心。
You know, so if it's a forest, all the trees are the same and they're sort of replicated in a grid, right, or rocks and things. And so you get the sense that it was, like, all very carefully placed and scenic in the sense of, like, scenery. As with most games, then, nature is little more than background, a placement. So, error two. Skip ahead a decade to gaming's 3D. period, when games, including Zelda, start centering nature in their gameplay.
那是1998年，《塞尔达传说：时之笛》。像素被大型、色彩鲜艳的多边形（通常是三角形）所取代，它们拼合在一起，创造出一个类似折纸的森林世界。在《时之笛》中，你仍然在海拉鲁，仍然在与怪物战斗。此时，大自然不仅是背景。大自然是游戏的关键部分。为了实现你的目标并取得进展，你需要与它互动。林克游泳，他搬起石头，他与一棵会说话的树聊天，
It's 1998, Zelda's 3D Akarina of Time. Pixels are replaced by large, brightly colored polygons, triangles, typically, that snap together to create an origami-like forest world. In Akarina of Time, you're still in Hyrule, still fighting monsters. At this time, nature is not just background. Nature is a key part of the game. To accomplish your goals and progress, you need to interact with it. Link swims, he lifts rocks, he chats up a talking tree,
这一切都是为了阻止坏人将翠绿的海拉鲁陷入毁灭。如果你回去看看《时之笛》通关过程中的画面，你会看到那种以非常具象和三维的方式穿越世界的愿景。《时之笛》属于一类3D游戏，《最终幻想7》、《小龙斯派罗》，它们赋予了自然更进化的角色。但与接下来的内容相比，这算不了什么，
all to prevent the bad guy from plunging green high roll into ruin. If you go back and look at footage from play-throughs of Ocarina of Time, you see the sort of vision of being able to traverse the world in a very embodied and three-dimensional way. Akarina of Time fit into a breed of 3D games, Final Fantasy 7, Spyrode the Dragon, which gave nature a more evolved role. But that was nothing compared to what came next,
一种新型游戏，一种将真正模糊虚拟自然与真实自然界限的游戏。第三时代，一个主导现代游戏的时代。开放世界。开放世界是一个附加在游戏上的代名词，意味着你作为玩家可以穿越这些虚拟空间，而没有受到限制的印象。
a new type of game, one that would truly blur the lines between virtual and real nature. Era 3, an era that dominates modern gaming. Open world. Open world is this moment. moniker that gets attached to games, meaning you as a player can traverse these virtual spaces without the impression of having limits.
在开放世界游戏中，大自然既不是布景，也不是达到目的的手段。它们具有身临其境的感觉，拥有看似无边无际的风景，而且它们的玩法通常是非线性的，在其中体验自然本身就可以是一个目标。思考游戏中的生态学，我认为这是一个巨大的发展，因为你现在可以讲述这样的故事：在所有外观上，你都可以在一个完全实现、身临其境的游戏环境中四处游荡。真正巨大的开放世界游戏在90年代和2000年代初开始涌现，《无尽的任务》和《魔兽世界》。到了2017年，你猜对了，塞尔达。《塞尔达传说：旷野之息》太疯狂了。林克不再是大型多边形的组合，而是一个超级详细的少年，亚麻色的头发在风中飘扬。他——也就是你——被扔进了一个巨大的
In open-world games, nature is neither just a place setting nor a means to an end. They are immersive with seemingly boundless landscapes, and their gameplay is often non-linear, where experiencing nature can be a goal in its own right. Thinking about ecology and games, I think it's a huge, it's a huge development because you can now tell stories where you can, by all appearances, wander around a fully realized, immersive game environment. Truly giant open world games started popping up in the 90s and early Aughts, EverQuest and World War. craft. And by 2017, you guessed it, Zelda. Zelda Breath of the Wild is wild. Link is no longer a composite of large polygons, but a hyper-detailed teenager with flaxen hair that whips in the wind. He slash you are dropped into an enormous
世界里，在那里你可以奔跑几个小时而不会撞到墙。如果你撞到墙，你可以攀爬。我不仅被游戏环境的美丽所折服，而且在非人类环境的生动性和自主性方面也彻底惊艳了。所以，你知道的，在《旷野之息》中，下雨时你攀爬东西会变得更加困难，这个事实太棒了。我欣喜若狂。海拉鲁的环境——沙漠、苔原、平原，它们实际上就是生态系统。它们的组成部分与你以及彼此互动。你可以驯服一匹野马，或采集蘑菇，或者什么都不做，世界仍在运转。河水流淌，雨水打湿岩石，熊猎捕鹿，树木燃烧并倒下，全都是自主发生的。《旷野之息》就是那种你可以放下手柄走开，
world where you can run for hours without hitting a wall. And if you hit a wall, you can climate. I was completely blown away by not only the beauty of the game environments, but also in terms of liveliness and agency of the non-human environment. So, you know, the fact that in Breath of the Wild, when it rains, you have more trouble climbing things was amazing. I was thrilled. The high rule environments, deserts, tundras, plains, they are practically ecosystems. Their components interact with you and each other. You can tame a wild horse or collect mushrooms or do nothing and the world keeps turning. Rivers flow, rain slicks rocks, bears hunt deer, trees burn and fall, all on their own. Breath of the Wild is one of those games
事情仍会继续发生的游戏。你也可以像你所说的那样留下来，好好欣赏一处风景优美的俯瞰点、一场暴风雨的来临，或者你知道的，比如一群野马路过，对吧？所以我认为这增加了玩家的真实感，也增加了玩家的利害关系，因为你在某种程度上更加脆弱。你成了那个环境的一部分，这在早期的游戏中是没有发生过的。《旷野之息》是一个例子，但今天我们正生活在开放世界游戏的黄金时代。
where you can put the controller down and you can walk away and things will continue to happen. And you can also stay like you're saying and just really enjoy a scenic overlook or a storm coming in or or, you know, like a herd of wild horses coming by, right? So I think that increases the sense of realism and also the sense of stakes for players because you are more vulnerable in some way. You're part of that environment in a way that didn't happen with earlier games. Breath of the Wild is one example, but today we're living. living in a golden age of open world games.
《荒野大镖客2》、《上古卷轴5：天际》、《刺客信条》、《猎人：荒野的召唤》、《无人深空》、《对马岛之魂》。人们玩这些游戏的方式各有不同。有些人专注于主要目标。有些人四处跳跃，拍摄蝴蝶的截图，真的。因为今天的游戏比以往任何时候都更接近真实的自然体验。当然，真正的自然体验对不同的人意味着不同的东西。我不知道。
Red Dead Redemption 2, Skyrim, Assassin's Creed, The Hunter, Call of the Wild, No Man Sky, Gosa, Tsushima. People play these games differently. Some focus on the main objective. Some bounce around, taking screenshots of butterflies, really. Because today's games are closer than ever to a true nature experience. Of course, true nature experience means different things to different people. I don't know.
这只是，四处走走太有趣了。我喜欢在游戏中四处走走。我就是喜欢，去散个步。卡西（Snifferish）喜欢《我的世界》并不是因为它看起来逼真。我的意思是，它全是方块。太阳以直角发光。但《我的世界》的自然，尽管它方方正正，却确实感觉很真实。这种真实感的一部分在于它的多样性。
It was just, it was so fun to walk around. I love walking around a game. I love just, like, taking a little stroll. Cassie, sniffer-ish, loves Minecraft not because it looks realistic. I mean, it's all blocks. The sun radiates at right angles. But Minecraft's nature, despite its blockiness, does feel real. Part of Minecraft's realism is its diversity.
游戏中有60多种不同的环境或生物群系，每种都有自己的植物、动物和风景，玩家可以接触到一种并非就在他们前门外的自然。在类似于经典的温带森林中长大，能够接触到那些我绝对无法接触到的其他生物群系，甚至包括海滩。我身处一个内陆州。我看不到海滩。这很有趣。而且它也让我能够把我的房子建在海滩上。我可以把我的房子建在雨林里，你知道的？我在现实生活中做不到这一点。《我的世界》的现实感也在于它的规模。如果说塞尔达感觉无边无际，那《我的世界》就是真的无边无际。
The game has over 60 different environments or biomes, each with their own plants, animals, and landscapes, players can access a kind of nature that is not right out their front door. Growing up in, like, the classic temperate forest, having access to those other biomes that I definitely don't have access to, like, beaches even. I'm in a landlock state. I don't see beaches. Like, it's interesting. And also it kind of lets me, I could build my house on a beach. I can build my house in a rainforest, you know? I can't do that in real life. The realism in Minecraft is also in its scale. If Zelda feels endless, Minecraft is endless.
你可以每天醒来，向东走，如果你愿意，永远不要停下来。有个家伙真的这么做了。他走了58天，然后才选择停下游戏，因为游戏并不会阻止他。开放世界的这些特征——它们的多样性和规模，你可以永远行走却永不看到相同场景的方式——这种体验之所以可能，是因为某种被称为程序生成的东西。
You can wake up every day, walk east, and never stop if you want. Some guy actually did that. He made it 58 days before he chose to stop the game, because the game wasn't going to stop him. These features of open worlds, their diversity and scale, the way you can walk forever and never see the same scene twice, that experience is possible because of some. called Procedural Generation.
程序生成是一种通过算法而非手动创造自然的技术。你不用在游戏中放置每一棵树。你给计算机规则，计算机就会为你填充场景。这是阿格尼斯·拉尔森告诉我的。她是《我的世界》制作方Mojang的游戏总监。不可能亲手设计一个无限世界的每一个部分。程序生成是我们能够创造这个拥有不同生物群系、不同类型积木的世界的原因。这里有海洋。我们创造大陆。
Procedural Generation is a technique that creates nature algorithmically, not manually. You don't place every tree in the game. You give the computer rules and the computer populates the scene for you. This is something Agnes Larson told me. She's game director at Mojang, maker of Minecraft. It's not possible to design each part of an endless world by hand. Procedural generation is the reason to why we can create this world with different biomes, different kind of building blocks. There are oceans. We create continents.
程序生成起源于70年代末，作为一种创建雏形但半随机化网格状环境的方法。如今，游戏的开发者向《我的世界》的软件讲述世界规则，比如红树林在哪里生长，或者哪些生物生活在哪个气候中，然后软件就会执行。每个东西在设计上都很简单，视觉效果很简单，机制很简单，这意味着它可以用无数复杂的方式组合在一起。
Procedural generation came out of the late 70s as a way of creating rudimentary but semi-randomized grid-like environments. Nowadays, Minecraft developers tell the game's software the rules of the world, like where mangrove trees grow, or which creatures live in which climate. and the software executes. Each thing is simple by design, and the visuals are simple, and the mechanics are simple, and that means that it can kind of be combined in an endless amount of complex ways.
《我的世界》游戏设计中的程序规则类似于自然规律。就像大自然一样，其魅力在于意想不到的组合。即使作为《我的世界》的开发者，阿格尼斯也曾对某些风景感到真诚的惊奇，因为并不是她发明了它们。不完全是。我记得走进这个地方，那是一座大山，然后有一个巨大的瀑布，因为山顶上生成了一个湖泊。
The procedural rules in Minecraft's game design are akin to the laws of nature. Just as with nature, the magic is in the unexpected combinations. Even as a Minecraft developer, Agnes has been genuinely surprised by some landscapes because she didn't invent them. Not exactly. I remember walking into this location that it was a big mountain and then there was a huge waterfall because a lake had generated on top of the mountain.
然后我们碰巧还生成了一个繁茂的洞穴生物群系。所以瀑布流入了那些从洞穴侧面垂下来的藤蔓中。这非常戏剧化，因为有如此多的反光和对比。正如游戏玩家和开发者所告诉我的，正是对自然的追求激发了诸如程序生成这样的技术。它还推动了新一轮图形技术的浪潮。
And then we also happened to generate a lush cave biome. So the waterfall went into these wines. that came down from, like, the sides of the caves. And it was just very dramatic because there was so much contrast. As gamers and developers told me, it is the pursuit of nature that inspired technologies, like procedural generation. It also fueled a new wave of graphics.
如果你有一段时间没看过全新的电子游戏，那就去看看吧，因为那些图形如果你没看过的话，简直太疯狂了。《最后生还者2》，其中很多都是临界于写实主义加上一点风格化。杰里米·哈克斯利是一位环境艺术家。他曾参与过那些因外观而备受赞誉的游戏，包括《神秘海域4》。还有《最后生还者第二部》，这部游戏被改编成了HBO剧集，其中真菌引发了僵尸末日。我没有被感染。我有免疫力。
Graphics that if you haven't seen a brand-new video game in a while, go look, because it's crazy. The Last of Us, too, a lot of it is borderline photorealism with a dash of style. Jeremy Huxley is an environmental artist. He's worked on games heralded for their looks, including Uncharted 4. And The Last of Us Part 2, the game turned HBO series, where Fungi calls the zombie apocalypse. I'm not infected. I'm immune.
对，我很幸运能够加入真菌团队工作。我专注于材质，所以我做了很多积雪和岩石之类的事情。《最后生还者2》和《神秘海域4》是线性游戏，严格来说不是开放世界，但它们是庞大的世界，在杰里米这样的人的努力下，它们看起来令人难以置信地逼真。他的工作是研究自然并将艺术与科技融合来模仿它。实际上，当我们在开发《神秘海域4》的技术时，我们并没有完全理解，例如，半透明性是如何在树叶上起作用的。
Yeah, I was lucky enough to get to work on the fungus team. And I was focused on materials, so I would do a lot of the same. snow and rocks and stuff like that. The Last of Us 2 and Uncharted 4 are linear games, technically not open world, but they are large worlds and they look unbelievably believable because of people like Jeremy. His job is to study nature and blend art and tech to mimic it. Actually, when we were developing the tech for Uncharted 4, we didn't fully understand, for example, like how translucency worked on leaves.
所以我们 literalmente（字面意思上）走出去，收集了一堆，然后我们拿了一个通常用于动画制作的灯箱，把光线投射穿过它们，看看它们是如何反应的。我们在那里做了很多笔记，然后我们就能模拟出那种效果。当你设计游戏环境时，你使用的是一个资产库，比如树木、石头。你可以从头开始设计它们，
So we literally went out, gathered a bunch, and then we took a light box, that you would use for, like, animating, cast light through them to kind of see how it reacted. And we took a lot of notes there, and then we were able to sort of simulate that. When you're designing a game environment, you use a library of assets, trees, rocks. You can design them from scratch,
这个过程被称为雕刻，这也是杰里米的强项。但你也可以用真实的树木和真实的石头来填充这个资产库，它们是从现实生活中扫描到虚拟世界中的。保真度极高，你现在 literalmente 可以创造真实感，因为如今你可以出门扫描自然。扫描听起来就像它字面上的意思，但达到了细致入微的水平。专业人士带着手持光或激光扫描仪进入野外，
a process called sculpting, which is Jeremy's forte. But you can also fill that library with real trees and real rocks, scanned from life into the virtual world. The fidelity level is extremely high, You can literally just create realism now because you can go out and scan nature these days. Scanning is what it sounds like, but on a meticulous level. Professionals go into the wild with handheld light or laser scanners
或者他们使用强力的相机设备，从你能想到的每一个角度对单个物体拍摄数千张照片。然后将这些数据上传到游戏引擎中。用于制作游戏的软件。这意味着你在游戏中碰到的某棵树，实际上可能是活树的数字幽灵。然后游戏引擎让这棵树复活，在微风中吹拂，在阳光下闪烁。
or they use intense camera equipment to take thousands of photos of a single object from every conceivable angle. That data is then uploaded to a game engine. Software used to make games. This means that some tree you bump into in the game may actually be the digital ghost of a living tree. Game engines then make the tree come to life to blow in the breeze and shimmer in the sun.
我现在使用的是虚幻引擎5。我们拥有疯狂的处理能力。你可以使用大量的几何体。材质对光的反应很自然，就像你刚才说的那样。甚至《我的世界》也在做类似的事情。这类事情做起来真的很困难，但我们拥有这种东西真的很强大。所以，程序生成创造了一个感觉动态且无限的游戏世界。
What I'm using currently is Unreal Engine 5. We have insane amounts of processing power. You can use tons of geometry. Materials react naturally to light, like you were saying. Even Minecraft is doing the similar thing. This sort of stuff is really difficult to do, but it's really powerful that we have this sort of thing. So, procedural generation creates a game world that feels dynamic and infinite.
扫描使世界变得美丽，正如真实自然之美那样。然后游戏引擎将其动画化。它们共同作用，使电子游戏中的自然感觉非常接近真实事物。但这种动态也是双向的，因为如今一些诞生于游戏的技术正被用来操纵真实的生活世界及其其中的位置。稍后会详细介绍。在许多方面，自然激发了游戏产业的灵感，这是合乎情理的。游戏是商业艺术，而艺术自有人在洞穴墙壁上画猪以来就在模仿自然。但也许更出人意料的是游戏产业在现实、切实层面上塑造生活世界的方式。
Scans make the world beautiful in a way that real nature is beautiful. And then game engines animate it into being. Together, they make the nature in video games feel very close to the real thing. But that dynamic also works in reverse, because today some of the technologies born from gaming are now being used to manipulate the real living world and are place in it. More on that in a minute. In a lot of ways, it makes sense that nature has inspired the games industry. Games are commercial art, and art has been emulating nature since someone drew a pig on a cave wall. But what's maybe less expected is the way the gaming industry has, on a real, tangible level, shaped the living world.
电子游戏对自然的影响有多大？在我的工作领域，影响很大。泰莎·法布里修斯在苏黎世的一家名为Esri的公司工作。Esri使用程序生成和游戏引擎等电子游戏技术来绘制真实世界的地图。甚至，重构它。你对数字孪生了解多少？如果我说数字孪生，这对你有什么意义吗？数字孪生是真实地点的功能性动画模拟。
How much have video games influenced nature? In my field of work, heavily. Tysha Fabritius works in Zurich for a company called Esri. Esri uses video game technologies like procedural generation and game engines to map the real world. Or even, recreate it. How much do you know about digital twins? If I say digital twins, does that mean anything to you? Digital twins are functioning animated simulations of a real place.
想象一下谷歌街景与《侠盗猎车手》的结合。苏黎世有一个。纽约有一个。德克萨斯州的科珀斯克里斯蒂有一个。你能以数字方式更身临其境地体验你的世界，你就能做出更好的决策，对吧？数字孪生主要用于城市规划。它们不是精确的复制品，而是某个地点的动态模型。
Think Google Street View meets Grand Theft Auto. Zurich has one. New York has one. Corpus Christi, Texas has one. The more immersive you can experience your world digitally, the better you'll be able to make decisions, right? Digital twins are used primarily in city planning. They're not exact replicas, but living models of a place.
它们之所以成为可能，是因为游戏行业开创的技术。游戏引擎是一个，程序生成是另一个。程序生成，即以算法创造世界的游戏技术，可以发明一个像《我的世界》那样的地方。它还可以使用现实世界数据中的规则，轻松地在数字上近似一个已经存在的地方。因此，与其让某人煞费苦心地雕刻每个建筑和树木，
And the reason they are possible, is because of technologies pioneered by the games industry. Game engines for one, procedural generation for another. Procedural generation, the game tech that creates worlds algorithmically, can invent a place like in Minecraft. It can also use rules in real-world data to digitally approximate a place that already exists, easily. So instead of some person painstakingly sculpting each building and tree
甚至扫描它们，你只需给计算机一张地图和关于地形的信息，比如每个建筑有多少层，或者每个街区有多少棵树。然后程序使用程序生成来发明其余部分，或者填补空白。然后，Esri利用游戏引擎让数字孪生变得生动起来。游戏引擎对一个地方进行动画处理，使得交通流动，雨水落下。其结果是一张身临其境的地图，它不仅看起来像它的现实生活孪生体，而且它的行为也与之相似。
or even scanning them, You can give the computer a map and information about the landscape, how many stories each building is, or how many trees on each block. And the program uses procedural generation to invent the rest, or fill in the blanks. Then, Esri brings the digital twin to life with game engines. Game engines animate a place so that traffic moves and rain falls. The result is an immersive map that doesn't just look like its real life, twin, it also acts like it.
当你把真实数据引入游戏引擎中，并且你可以创造出这些令人信服的、高度视觉化、极具沉浸感的体验时，这显然会“改变游戏规则”，当涉及到在现实世界中做出真正的决策时。Esri用游戏引擎做的事情在气候变化时代特别有帮助。随着大自然本身的变化，我们需要想象将会发生什么以及如何为最坏的情况做准备。夏威夷考艾岛使用Esri技术来模拟海平面上升，并观察它将如何影响该地区。然后该县通过了新的建筑条例。
When you're bringing in real data into game engines and you can create these believable, very visual, very immersive experiences that obviously, quote-unquote, changes the game when it comes to actually making real decisions in the real world. What Ezri does with game engines has been particularly helpful in the age of climate change. As nature itself changes, we need to imagine what will come and how to prepare for the worst. Kauai County, Hawaii, used Esri Tech to animate sea level rise and see how it would affect the area. The county then adopted new construction ordinances.
美国国家海洋和大气管理局使用它来可视化华盛顿特区内的热岛效应。洛杉矶利用Esri在今年早些时候的野火期间进行响应和恢复工作。泰莎说Esri可以重构这些火灾，让你一遍又一遍地重新审视它们，以了解哪里出了问题以及如何为下一次做计划。你可以身临其境地看到它，因为有数据和3D模型，一切看起来都是真的。所以你能看到它并完全沉浸其中，这有助于你规划如何减轻这种影响。
The National Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration used it to visualize heat islands in D.C. L.A. used Esri for response and recovery efforts during the wildfires earlier this year. Taisha says Esri can recreate those fires, allow you to revisit them again and again to understand what went wrong and how to plan for next time. You can be there and see it, and because the data's there and the 3D models, everything looks real. And so you can see it and you're fully immersed in, and it helps you to plan for ways that you can mitigate this then.
这不仅适用于城市。Esri与大自然保护协会合作，在加利福尼亚州创立了康塞普西翁角的数字孪生，这是一个查帕拉尔灌木林和橡树林与海岸灌木丛和海带林交汇的地方。在那里，外来入侵的冰叶植物正在排挤当地的植物群。研究人员正在利用康塞普西翁角的数字孪生来测试在现实生活中（IRL）消灭这些植物的方法。从理论上讲，你可以预测哪些想法能击退入侵者，哪些不能。这是一个数字试验场，就像游戏一样。尝试，失败，回应。
And this is not just for cities. Esri partnered with the Nature Conservancy to create a digital twin of point conception in California, a place where Chaparral and Oakwoodlands meets coastal scrub and help forests. There, invasive ice plants are displacing the local flora. Researchers are using the digital twin of point conception to test out ways to eliminate the plants before going IRL in real life. In theory, you could predict which ideas will fight off invasives and which won't. It is a digital proving ground, like a game. Try, fail, respond.
再次。虽然这种对更真实的虚拟自然的无休止追求已经融入了预测海平面上升和准备野火的工具中，但它也伴随着代价，可以说这个代价正在提高海平面并点燃火焰。对我来说最重要的事情是，几乎令人震惊的碳排放量，
again. While this endless pursuit of a truer virtual nature has made its way into tools for predicting sea level rise and preparing for wildfires, it also comes at a cost, one that is arguably raising the level of the sea and sparking the flames. The number one thing for me is the almost staggering amount of carbon emissions. that come from playing games, from making games, and from all the other peripheral activities around the games industry. You just broke a lot of gamers' hearts out there.
这些排放来自于玩游戏、制作游戏，以及来自游戏产业周围所有其他外围活动。你刚刚伤了很多游戏玩家的心。我必须指出这一点。是的。本·亚伯拉罕研究数字游戏与气候变化。不，他并不讨厌游戏。命运是他的最爱游戏。但他的最爱地球也是，嗯，地球。所以本在可持续游戏联盟工作，这是一个试图为清洁行业做出贡献的非营利组织。
I just have to point that out. Yeah. Ben Abraham researches digital games in climate change. And no, he doesn't hate gaming. Destiny is his favorite game. But also his favorite Earth is, well, Earth. So Ben works for the Sustainable Games Alliance, a nonprofit trying to clean up
为地球服务。一项艰巨的任务，因为游戏公司不必披露他们的排放量。我能得出的最好数字，而且这只是一个粗略的估算数据，大约是每年5000万吨二氧化碳。大多数人会觉得，好吧，听起来很多，因为这是一个“百万”，但那到底是多少？嗯，它比好莱坞还要大。它的排放量可能和欧洲中等大小的国家差不多，比如瑞典或希腊。图形、游戏引擎，这些都在消耗能量。如果没有更多的太阳能和风能，那就意味着为了娱乐而燃烧化石燃料。
the industry for the planet. A difficult task because game companies do not have to disclose their emissions. The best number that I've been able to come up with, and it's just a ballpark figure, really, is around about 50 million tons of CO2 per annum. And most people will just be like, okay, that sounds like a lot because it's a million, but what is that? Well, it's bigger than Hollywood. It's probably around about the same sort of emissions as a media. a big-sized European country, like Sweden or Greece. Graphics, game engines, it all bleeds energy. Without more solar and wind, that means burning fossil fuels for the sake of play.
尽管该行业采取了一些明智的举措来使游戏更加节能，但燃料仍在继续燃烧。排放量……绝对在上升。我的意思是，几乎毫无疑问，是的。我认为我们需要正视这一事实，
And despite some smart industry moves to make games more energy efficient, the fuels keep burning. And emissions... They are absolutely going up. I mean, there's almost no question, yeah. And I think we need to reckon with that fact. and, you know, figure out what is a sustainable path for the games industry? I don't think that we've got a vision of one yet. Part of what's fueling emissions is, ironically, the push to create more realistic environments.
并且，你知道的，弄清楚游戏产业的可持续发展道路是什么？我认为我们还没有一个这样的愿景。讽刺的是，推动排放的因素之一正是创造更逼真环境的冲动。想想扫描所需的CPU/能量。你对一棵树拍摄数千张照片，然后将它们上传到软件中，该软件将该树渲染为带有多个细节层的3D模型，并专门对其进行校准，例如真实地反映光线。然后将该模型输入到由AI支持的引擎中，在那里它被下载并可能用于程序化地填充虚拟世界，这一切都是为了让我们去欣赏那棵假树，而不是去外面那些饱受干旱摧残的树木早已和游戏里的树木一样不再存活的现实世界。不管怎样，有些人有不同的看法。游戏生态学教授阿琳达·张认为这更像是一个好坏参半的问题。我必须承认强大的计算机和图形处理器对世界的环境影响，
Think of the CPU slash energy needed for scanning. You take thousands of photos of one tree and upload them into software, which renders that tree as a 3D model with multiple layers of detail and especially calibrates it to, say, authentically reflect light. And then that model is fed into an AI-supported engine where it's downloaded and perhaps used to procedurally fill in the virtual world, all in the name of getting us to admire the fake tree instead of going outside where the real drought-ridden trees are no longer any more alive than the one in the game. Anyway, some people see it differently. Game Ecology professor Alenda Chang thinks it's more of a mixed bag. I have to acknowledge the sort of environmental impact of the powerful computers and graphical processes.
对吧？但我认为游戏确实对人们对自然世界的理解、感知或态度产生了深远的影响，或者至少它们可以做到这一点。游戏是媒介。媒介对人们的心理有巨大的影响，而人们对自然有着巨大的影响。充满大地，征服它。一本书曾这样写过，人们把这话听到心里去了。但游戏中的信息可能与《旧约》截然不同。以《世界》为例。砍倒一棵树，你需要种一棵来替代它。
units on the world, right? But I think also games do have a really profound influence on people's understandings or perceptions or attitudes toward the natural world, or at least they can. Games are media. Media have a huge effect on people psychologically, and people have a huge effect on nature. Fill the earth and subdue it. Set a book once, people took that to heart. But the messaging in games can be quite different than the Old Testament. Take Minecraft. Punch down a tree and you'll need to plant another one to replace it.
砍倒所有的树，你就出局了。资源是有限的，就像大自然一样。也许这听起来很小，但还是那句话，《世界》，一款由瑞典小工作室Mojang开发的游戏，是世界上最受欢迎的游戏。20%的玩家是儿童。他们能学到东西。一项小型研究发现，玩《世界》的孩子比没玩过的孩子学到了更多关于可持续性的知识。
Punch down all the trees and you're out. Resources are finite, just like in nature. Maybe that sounds small, but again, Minecraft, a game created by Mojang, a small studio in Sweden, Minecraft is the most popular game in the world. 20% of its players are kids. They pick stuff up. One small study found kids who played Minecraft learned more about sustainability
并且有轶事证据。对我来说，Mojang在某些方面拥有的力量相当疯狂且神奇。你知道的，仅仅是加入美西螈的决定，对吧？是的，美西螈，那种长着尖锐朋克摇滚头鳃的极度濒危蝾螈。
than kids who didn't. And there's anecdotal evidence. It's pretty wild and magical to me the power that Mojang has in some ways. You know, just the decision to include axelotles, right? Yes, axelottles, the critically endangered salamanders with pointy punk rock headgills.
在《我的世界》于2021年将它们加入游戏后，谷歌搜索量激增。当时一个美西螈保护区告诉NPR，几乎每个来访的孩子都是因为《我的世界》才来的。游戏，你知道的，是这些真正不可思议的讲故事机器，它们可以给我们留下一种感觉或一种体验。这就足够了。是的。这可能足以促使某人以不同的方式思考，或者关心不仅仅是他们自己的东西。你的衣服是专门用来防晒的吗？
After Minecraft added them to the game in 2021, Google searches spiked. An Acelotto Sanctuary told NPR at the time that nearly every kid who visited came because of Minecraft. Games are, you know, these really incredible storytelling machines and they can just leave us with a feeling or they can leave us with a sensation. And that might be enough. Yeah. That might be enough to propel somebody to think differently or to care about something that isn't just them. As your wardrobe a specific choice against the sun?
在 Minecraft 于 2021 年将它们加入游戏后，谷歌搜索量激增。当时，一个薮猫庇护所告诉美国国家公共电台，几乎每个来访的孩子都是因为 Minecraft。你知道，游戏是非常不可思议的故事讲述机器，它们可以给我们留下某种感觉或体验。这就足够了。是的。这或许就足以促使人们改变思维方式，去关心不仅仅是他们自己的事物。你的衣橱是为了防晒而做出的特殊选择吗？
Yes, yeah, I'm like always wearing pants in summer. Over the years, Minecraft-loving, allergic to the sun, Cassie, has found ways to be more outdoorsy again. With the right season, the right weather, the right clothing, and sometimes a really annoying journalist who won't shut up about nature, Cassie still sees green. So a while back, we went for a hike in the foothills of Western Vermont. Do you ever just, like, look out and see the world in blocks?
是的，我夏天总是穿着裤子。这些年来，热爱《我的世界》、对阳光过敏的卡西一直在寻找重新回归户外的方法。有了合适的季节、合适的天气、合适的衣服，有时还有一个对大自然喋喋不休的讨厌记者，卡西依然能看到满眼绿色。所以不久前，我们去佛蒙特州西部的山麓徒步旅行。你有没有过那种感觉，向外看去，把世界看成是一个个方块？
No, actually. Yeah, I feel like I'm more focused on translating our world into Minecraft than Minecraft into our world, if that makes sense. So you're not punching trees? No. Definitely not. Cassie, their partner and I, went in our way through white birches and red maples and across a field of tall grass.
没有，其实没有。是的，我觉得我更专注于把我们的世界翻译成《我的世界》，而不是把《我的世界》翻译成我们的世界，如果这说得通的话。所以你没有在撸树？没有。绝对没有。卡西、他们的伴侣和我，一路穿过白桦树和红枫树，穿过一片高高的草地。
There was a breeze, birds, nature was moving. Oh, look, there's a little snake. Oh, there it goes. Okay. We followed trail signs and a dirt path, reminders that even in reality, few places are truly natural. Like players in Minecraft, we've sculpted this world. But even under the heaviest footprint, there is something there, something beyond ourselves and our ambitions.
有微风，有鸟儿，大自然在运动。哦，看，有一条小蛇。哦，它游走了。好的。我们顺着小路标志和泥土小径前行，这些都在提醒我们，即使在现实中，也很少有真正自然的地方。就像《我的世界》里的玩家一样，我们塑造了这个世界。但即使在最沉重的足迹之下，那里也有一些东西，一些超越我们自身和我们野心的东西。
That something is and will always be irreplicable. because we didn't make it. And that is quite a thing. Should we go to the end? Yeah, sure. All right. To the parking lot. To the parking lot.
那东西是，并且永远是不可复制的，因为不是我们制造的。这真是一件了不起的事。我们要去尽头吗？行，当然。好的。去停车场。去停车场。
Yay. So we can get in our cars. Go play video games. Yeah. So, Roman Mars. Ben Brock Johnson. Do you know what I love about those huge open world games like Ghosts of Tsushima, the game where you play a samurai defending his Japanese island from the first Mongol invasion?
耶。这样我们就可以上车了。去玩电子游戏。是的。那么，罗曼·马斯。本·布洛克·约翰逊。你知道我最喜欢那些巨大的开放世界游戏什么吗，比如《对马岛之魂》，那个扮演武士保卫他的日本岛屿免受第一次蒙古入侵的游戏？
I don't know everything you love about them, but what do you love? I love me a side quest, you know? Side quest, of course. Side quest. The little mission you can. do that's not necessarily part of the big mission. In Ghost of Tsushima, they have so many of these. You can practice your sword skills on these bamboo things. You can follow foxes to shrines where you pray. You can write haikus. There's lots of side quests you can do. And we have one more side quest for our hidden levels listeners on the endless thread feed, right? Yeah, that's right. And this one
我不知道你对它们的喜爱是不是全部，但你最喜欢什么？我很喜欢支线任务，你知道的？支线任务，当然。支线任务。你可以完成的小任务，不一定是大任务的一部分。在《对马岛之魂》里，有很多这样的任务。你可以在这些竹子上练习剑术。你可以跟着狐狸去神社祈祷。你可以写俳句。有很多支线任务你可以做。我们为 Endless Thread 订阅源上的隐藏关卡听众准备了另一个支线任务，对吧？是的，没错。这个任务
comes to us from producer Grace Tatter. Hi, Ben. Hi, Roman. Hey. Hey. Grace, tell us a little bit more about this journey you are taking us on with your side quest. What's the story? Okay, so this is a story about a renowned surgeon. He's a pioneer in his field, and he has a theory that playing video games could help other doctors be better surgeons. Does this surprise you as an idea? Like gamers could be better surgeons, Roman? Oh my God. No, it does not surprise me as an idea. Because, you know, we've talked about this, like the dexterity, the tools, the reaction, all that sort of stuff, is built into video games, and I imagine it's like a cornerstone to what makes a good surgeon a good surgeon. Would it surprise you to learn that non-gamer surgeons might be skeptical of this idea?
由制作人格蕾丝·塔特带给我们。嗨，本。嗨，罗曼。嘿。嘿。格蕾丝，跟我们多讲讲你带我们踏上的这段支线任务之旅吧。这个故事是什么？好的，这是一个关于一位知名外科医生的故事。他是他所在领域的先驱，他有一个理论，即玩电子游戏可以帮助其他医生成为更好的外科医生。这个想法让你感到惊讶吗？就像游戏玩家可以成为更好的外科医生一样，罗曼？哦，天哪。不，这个想法一点也不让我惊讶。因为，你知道的，我们讨论过这个，比如灵巧度、工具、反应，所有这些东西，都内置在电子游戏中，我想这就像是造就一个优秀外科医生的基石。如果你得知非游戏玩家外科医生可能会对外科医生抱有怀疑态度，你会感到惊讶吗？
I mean, the funny thing about doctors in general is that doctors have some fealty to tradition. Yes. That makes these types of developments, you know, sometimes hard for some of them to accept. Yeah, that's exactly right. The doctor in this story, it was quite the quest for him to prove this theory in the 90s and the 2000s, because a lot of people really did not believe that video games had any place in medicine. Dr. Rosser is considered one of the best at this in the world, and it's all because he figured out something no one else had thought of.
我的意思是，关于医生的一件有趣的事是，医生对传统有一定的忠诚度。是的。这使得这些类型的发展，你知道的，有时很难被他们中的一些人接受。是的，完全正确。故事中的这位医生，在90年代和2000年代证明这个理论对他来说是一次相当大的探索，因为很多人真的不相信电子游戏在医学上有任何地位。罗斯瑟博士被认为是世界上这方面的顶尖人物之一，这一切都是因为他想出了一些其他人没有想到的东西。
That was a big breakthrough. You know, he said, oh, Mom, look, I plan donkey come, and it still can help me save lives. Roman, that story is ready for us to listen to right now in our feed, Endless Threat. And coming up Friday on the final boss of Hidden Levels, we bring you a dispatch from the console wars. Sega was the challenger, right? Sega was never the king.
那是一个巨大的突破。你知道，他说，哦，妈妈，看，我玩《大金刚》，它依然能帮我拯救生命。罗曼，那个故事已经准备好让我们在我们的订阅源 Endless Thread 中收听了。周五即将播出的隐藏关卡最终Boss节目中，我们将为您带来来自主机大战的报道。世嘉是挑战者，对吧？世嘉从来都不是王者。
Sega was just coming up to the king and asking for a fight. This episode was produced by Dean Russell, edited by Kelly Prime. Mix, sound design, and music composition by Paul Vikis, Additional mixing by Martin Gonzalez. Series theme by Swan Real and Paul Bikis. The super cool music by Swan and Paul for Hidden Levels is being released as an album. You can listen everywhere.
世嘉只是走到王者面前要求一战。本集由迪恩·拉塞尔制作，凯利·普莱姆剪辑。混音、声音设计和音乐创作由保罗·维基斯完成，马丁·格雷赞助额外混音。系列主题曲由斯旺·里尔和保罗·比基斯创作。斯旺和保罗为《隐藏关卡》创作的超酷音乐将作为专辑发布。你可以在任何地方收听。
You stream music. Fact-checking by Graham Hesha. Special thanks to Samuel Auberg, Alex Beecham, Tracy Fullerton, Will Mattia, Kelsey Myers, and Mike Rojou. The managing producer for Hidden Levels is Chris Barubei, Hidden Levels was created by me, Ben Brock Johnson, while dancing in a Fortnite game lobby with power-ups and cheat codes thanks to Team 99% Invisible and Team Endless Threat. 99% Invisible's executive producer is Kathy 2. Kurt Kohloste is the digital director.
你流媒体音乐。事实核查由格雷厄姆·赫沙完成。特别感谢塞缪尔·奥伯格、亚历山大·比彻姆、特雷西·富勒顿、威尔·马蒂亚、凯尔西·迈尔斯和迈克·罗茹。《隐藏关卡》的执行制作人是克里斯·巴鲁贝伊，《隐藏关卡》由我、本·布洛克·约翰逊在《堡垒之夜》游戏大厅里伴随着道具和秘籍跳舞时创建，感谢 99% Invisible 团队和 Endless Thread 团队的帮助。99% Invisible 的执行制作人是凯西 2。库尔特·科洛斯特是数字总监。
Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Jason Deliom, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lajmadon, Jacob Medina Gleason, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of the logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. the art for hidden levels was created by Aaron Nestor. We are part of the Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California.
德兰妮·霍尔是我们的资深编辑。团队的其他成员包括杰森·德利奥姆、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·莱、拉贾马顿、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森、乔·罗森伯格和我，罗曼·马斯。99% 的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。《隐藏关卡》的艺术作品由亚伦·内斯特创作。我们是 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。
Endless Threat is a production of WBUR, Boston's NPR. The rest of our team tackling Unsolved Mysteries, untold histories, and other wild stories from the internet, includes my illustrious co-host, Amory Siebertson, managing producers, Summit to Joshi, editor, Meg Kramer, producers Grace Tatter, Franny Monaghan, and sound designer, Emily Jenkowski. See you on Friday, everybody. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Endless Thread 是波士顿 NPR 旗下 WBUR 的制作。我们的团队致力于解决未解之谜、不为人知的历史和来自互联网的其他狂野故事，包括我杰出的联合主持、阿莫里·西伯森、执行制作人、萨米特·托·乔希、编辑梅格·克雷默、制作人格蕾丝·塔特、弗兰妮·莫纳汉以及声音设计师艾米丽·扬科夫斯基。大家周五见。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。